so you're a big tobacco in the 1960s
like Philip Morris or RJ Reynolds you've
been making billions getting everyone
hooked on your addictive cigarettes
and one of your favorite audiences to
Market to is kids see kids are a
marketing gold mine if you can get a 12
year old kid hooked on Camel cigarettes
that kid is only gonna smoke camels for
the rest of their lives it's like
growing up with Coke instead of Pepsi by
appealing to kids you were creating
lifelong customers but that's not even
the best part the best part is that kids
are infinitely easier to Market to
unlike adults with adults do you have to
appeal to complex desires like status
sex jealousy greed but with kids all you
gotta do is throw in a few cartoon
characters some bright colors maybe some
new flavors and boom you're good to go
and marketing to kids have been working
like a charm for decades by the 60s you
were in your golden years this was the
peak of cigarette acceptability around
the world but by the 70s everything
started to go downhill that's when
public opinion started shifting against
smoking suddenly advertising your
cigarettes all over TV magazines and
newspapers wasn't okay anymore even
worse peddling cigarettes to school kids
became illegal kids were your favorite
demographic the easiest demographic to
Market to the demographic that gave you
your highest return on ad spend you
can't lose the kids but you also don't
want to go to prison so the writing was
on the wall if you didn't take your
money and marketing expertise and apply
it to something else that could be
marketed to kids it was gonna be over
for you you needed something that was
just as addictive as cigarettes but that
was as socially acceptable as toothpaste
but what could that be hmm what about
sugar think about it everyone loves
sugar and yet sugar can be more
addictive than cocaine
if you could get your foot in the door
of the sugary Foods industry and take
all the knowledge you've learned on how
to get kids addicted to cigarettes but
apply it to Sugar you would be golden
and it was in this crisis this turning
point this fork in the road that big
tobacco started systematically taking
over big food
shout out to America uncovered with
Chris chapel and Shelly for covering the
story first big fan I'll link to the
channel below and let's get into it
[Music]
thank you
and by the way guys this video got
demonetized hooray if you think videos
like this are important for people to
watch and you want to support the
channel monetarily consider clicking
that join button below and this essence
of Shameless ask for peer donations by
becoming a member you get a new private
documentary every single month that will
never be released publicly because they
are just flat out too controversial one
of my personal favorites is a recent one
we did on the ulterior motives behind
pushing climate change and hence it has
to do with the rich Nations wanting to
keep the poor Nations poorer and you can
watch it right now by clicking that join
button below along with all the other
ones we put out on the rosh Charles MK
Ultra F3 jepskin Iran CIA black sites
and much much more so pause the video
and click that join button below now
[Music]
the first vertical that big tobacco
targeted was sugary drinks fruit juices
concentrate sodas and everything in
between think about it sure candy and
chocolate are packed full of sugar but
even in the 70s candy had a bad
reputation everyone already Associated
it with diabetes and obesity but fruit
juices fruit juices are pernicious on
the outside fruit juices have this Aura
of being Natural Healthy full of vitamin
C but on the inside it's a completely
different story just one small serving
of Capri Sun contains one of six
teaspoons of sugar about the same amount
of sugar as in a single serving of M M's
think about how genius this was how many
packets of M M's could a person really
eat in a day two maybe three but how
many packets of Capri Sun could that
same person drink in a day a lot more
than just straight up candy that's for
sure a lot of you may have fond memories
of drinking more than three packets of
Capri Sun in a day growing up as a kid
yes sugary drinks and fruit juices were
the perfect Target and you wasted no
time getting into the game in 1963 RJ
dinos but Hawaiian Punch and in 1988
Altria Philip Morris's parent company
bought crass food which owned Capri Sun
and Tang Altria paid 13 billion dollars
for crass Foods making it the biggest
acquisition outside of the energy sector
in American history that's how important
getting your hands on sugary drinks was
for you and with your foot firmly in the
door it was time to make the sugary
drinks industry your own your plan take
everything you've learned from marketing
cigarettes to make sweet drinks like
Tang Hawaiian Punch and Capri Sun the
most marketed consumables on the planets
and your main target the one demographic
that loves sugar more than anyone else
kids
here too
[Music]
did tobacco have boiled cigarette
marketing down to a science they
marketed smoking to women who want to
lose weight they paid doctors to
prescribe cigarettes to their patients
and claim that it was dust and germs not
cigarettes that made them sick they got
celebrities to endure cigarette brands
and they made sure that you couldn't
watch TV go to a football match or read
a magazine without seeing at least one
cigarette ad and then there was the
child focus marketing cartoon characters
adding fun new flavors to their
cigarettes or even getting schools to
open smoking lounges for their high
school students and in 1987 when it came
time to aim your marketing machine from
cigarettes to Sugar one of your
Executives boasted quote we've decided
to focus our marketing on kids where we
know our strength is the greatest End
quotes quote this year Cooley would be
the most heavily promoted kids trademark
in America End quotes Hawaiian Punch
used to be marketed as a cocktail mixer
for adults but once you got your depends
on it you pumped up the flavor of sugar
content and switched to more
kid-friendly cans and juice boxes you
even took a page out of your Camel
cigarette marketing Playbook and
developed a fun little mascot called
Punchy to draw in even more kids Punchy
was the direct counterpart to Joe Camel
the Camel cigarette mascot and Punchy
was everywhere on school bus lunch boxes
Comics clothes Punchy became known as
the best salesman Hawaiian Punch ever
had but Hawaiian Punch was just a start
next on your list was Kool-Aid
originally a drink marketed to families
for outings and special occasions but
families streaking Kool-Aid once a week
wasn't gonna make you rich so just like
a wine punch you rebranded Kool-Aid to
be the most kid-friendly drink in the
country enter the Kool-Aid man and
Kool-Aid collaborations with everything
from Barbie to Hot Wheels but even that
wasn't enough for you you wanted
Kool-Aid to be everywhere all the time
so you took it one step further and
created the Kool-Aid kids loyalty
program the Kool-Aid version of the
Marlboro Country Store that used to sell
branded clothes camping gear and
accessories to smokers except with this
one kids everywhere would be playing
with Cooley Brenna toys eating Kool-Aid
ice pops drinking [__] shots and
adding powdered Kool-Aid to their water
Hawaiian Punch Kool-Aid tang and Capri
Sun became your new Marlboro camel and
Virginia Slims they were National
bestsellers addictive National
bestsellers they were the first thing
any thirsty kid reach for when they got
the chance but it was still not enough
remember you needed to create lifelong
customers and to make a lifelong
customer you would need to get kids so
addicted to your drinks that they can
never imagine life without them
nice Hawaiian Punch sure
[Music]
just adding sugar to fruity drinks
wasn't enough to get kids addicted to
them for the long term years of
developing fun cigarette flavors like
Menthol and strawberry had taught you
the importance of taste in the addiction
process back in your tobacco selling
Glory Days you paid actual scientists to
study the effects of flavors and colors
on the brain and how you could use that
to get more people to start smoking so
you did the same thing here with sugary
drinks you recruited those same tobacco
studying scientists to determine exactly
what flavors and colors kids like best
but it didn't end there next up you
added in the additives untested
chemicals and concentrated sugar syrups
that gave these drinks a very unique
taste a very unique taste that you
couldn't get anywhere else so if a kid
fell in love with a specific Kool-Aid
flavor their only choice was to buy more
of that Kool-Aid flavor to quench their
addiction sure no one knew what large
amounts of these additives would do to
these kids in the long run but who cares
and just like in your tobacco testing
years to make sure no one could accuse
you issue of using harmful ingredients
in your products you want bacteria tried
and true tactic of paying off scientists
see the FDA allows companies to Market
food without their oversight as long as
they are generally recognized as safe or
grass for short and who decides if a
food is grass or not food scientists the
exact same food scientists you use to
certify your cigarette flavors as safe
all those years ago and for some reason
you found out by paying them two
thousand dollars a day for Consulting
Services tends to result in them
improving your artificial additives
without question huh who would have
thought so what the size and sugar on
your side big tobacco was back and now
they were bigger than ever your products
became so popular led by the 1980s
Cooley was the number one soft drink
among kids 12 and under and it could be
found in more than 80 percent of
households with children America's
future have become hooked on this
artificial juice that is somehow allowed
to be called food but then just like
with cigarettes the public started
getting suspicious about sugar and
suddenly you had to go on the defensive
[Music]
it froze so clean and sweet they eat it
when it's freshly cut and then that's
quiet once the public started realizing
how addicted kids have become the sugar
they became Furious wasn't it enough
that you had already made Millions
addicted to cigarettes and now you were
doing the same with sugar if you were
gonna say face you had to start making
excuses fast so that's exactly what you
did just like when you told the word
cigarettes weren't bad for your health
you got soft drink companies to claim
sugar had nothing to do with obesity and
illness you blame parents for not
choosing to give their kids healthier
drinks which is true how was it your
father kiss for drinking liters of
Coolidge and Capri Sun every day wasn't
it their responsibility as parents to
keep their kids healthy the more parents
pointed the finger at your marketing the
bigger your excuses became but in the
end not even playing the blame game was
enough to save your reputation if your
sugary drink Empire was gonna have any
chance of surviving it would have to
break away from Big tobacco so by the
early 2000s most of the food brands
owned by big tobacco parted ways the
association between kid-friendly drinks
and deadly cigarettes just wasn't gonna
work today big to bet tackle and Bigfoot
are two completely separate entities but
one common factor remains their
marketing even decades after the split
big food companies are still using Big
tobacco's Marketing methods to get kids
and adults hooked on their products but
the spell has wore off today the masses
are no longer fooled by sugary drinks
it's now common knowledge that these
sugary drinks aren't good for you but
you know what the public is fooled by
today plant-based meats you see
plant-based meat is a lie they say it's
about having empathy for animals they
say it's for the environment they say
it's healthy when in reality it is all
about money plant-based meat companies
have hijacked our compassion to sell us
imitation meat that is made out of a
bunch of cheap affordable industrial
chemicals and ingredients soy protein
made from soybeans made in a solvent
called hexane a known human neurotoxin
red number three a food diet that's a
carcinogen that's banned in cosmetics
caramel coloring tertiary
bitohydrocanone sodium Tripoli phosphate
yum these are just some of the
ingredients found in plant-based meat
ingredients that are not plant-based and
are way cheaper than growing grass-fed
cows which we've been eating for
hundreds of thousands of years and we
expose all of it on our new channel
called evil food supply flip the card on
the screen to watch our new video
exposing plant-based Meats now I created
this new channel because health is
wealth and to force myself to study this
stuff so you and I both benefit click
the card on the screen to watch now
foreign